يصرح احتاج اربعه انواع وعشرين ساعه فقط
لايقاف الحربي في اوكرانيا سياح يوافقون
تحول شوارع باريس الى انهارا من القمامه
الكشف عن ممتلكات سرقها اللصوص من فيلا
محمد صلاح هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم
من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات جديده اثار تفاعلا واسعا في
السوشيال ميديا قال الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب انه المرشح الرئاسي
الوحيد الذي يمكنه الحيل دون وقوع حرب
عالميه جديده وخلال تجمع حاشد لمؤيديه في
ولايه ايوا اكد ترامب ان اعاده انتخابه
كرئيس للولايات المتحده في عام 2024 هي
فقط التي ستنقذ البلاد من خطر اندلاع
الحرب العالميه الثالثه مضيفا انه يستطيع
وقف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه خلال 24
ساعه وقال ايضا ان اداره بيضا غير قادره
على تحدث بشكل صحيح وستقود البلاد الى حرب
نوويه قد تنهي العالم على الارجح
في احدث حلقه في مجموعه من تجارب الاسلحه
اعلن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخين بل السينيين قصي
المدى الى البحر قباله ساحلها الشرقي هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الكوريه الجنوبيه اوضحت
في بيان ان الصاروخين قطع مسافه قدرت
بحوالي 620 كيلومترا عشيره الى ان الجيش
الكوريه الجنوبي على درجات تاهب عاليه وفي
وضع الجاهزيه الكامله بتنسيق وثيق مع
الولايات المتحده فيما قالت القياده
الامريكيه في المحيطين الهندي والهادئ ان
الصاروخين لم يمثل تهديدا مباشرا للقوات
او الاراضي التابعه للولايات المتحده او
لحلفائها
بعد اسبوع على بدء اضراب عمال جمع
النفايات احتجاجا على مشروع اصلاح نظام
التقاعد في فرنسا تكدست اكياس القمامه في
شوارع العاصمه باريس بشكل ملفت جدا مقاطع
فيديو منتشره بشكل واسع على السوشيال
ميديا اظهرت عددا من السياح وهم يلتقطون
صور للقمامه التي تكدست في الشوارع وامام
المقاهي وحتى عند المعالم السياحيه
الشهيره في العاصمه الفرنسيه اما الرائحه
الكريهه فتملا المكان فيما تصاعد دعوات
داخل المدينه لاجبار عمال جمع النفايات
على العمل او اللجوء الى الشركات الخاصه
الى مصر هذه المره حيث تستمر الاجهزه
الامنيه المختصه بالتحقيق في سرقه فيلا
اللاعب محمد صلاح والكائنات في منطقه
التجمع الاول بالقاهره وسائل الاعلام
افادت نقلا عن مصادر امنيه ومحليه بان
المسروقات انحصرت حتى الان في اجهزه
الاستقبال التلفزيوني رسيفرز وبعض الملابس
الرياضيه الخاصه بنجم ليفربول اضافه الى
اختفاء عددا من الميداليات الرياضيه فيما
لا تزال عمليه حصر محتويات السرقه مستمره
اذ بدات اجهزه الامن بمراجعه كاميرات
المراقبه وتم توسيع دائره الاشتباه وسؤال
جميع العاملين في محيط الفيلا
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرنا الاخير كشف خبير الزلازل
الهولنديس في تغريده جديده عن موعد حصول
نشاط زلزاليا كبيرا خلال الايام المقبله
الذي توقع حدوث الزلزال المدمر بدايه
فبراير الماضي بتركيا قال اننا على موعد
مع ما اسمه تقارب الهندسه الكوكبيه في
الفتره المنتدمه بين الخامس عشر الى 17 من
شهر مارس الحليب ما يعني اننا سنشهد حدوث
زلزال او نشاط زلزالي كبير تقريبا بين
السادس عشر والتاسع عشر من شهر مارس فيما
اثارت هذه التغريده الرعب لدى البعض في
السوشيال ميديا وراى اخرون ان توقعات
هوغوبيت نادرا ما تصيب بالتالي لا داعي
للذعر او الخوف